all right we're now live for the First
Philosophy pop-up of the month of
September it's on September 11th so I
thought that a fitting topic for this
one might be to talk about national
security and terrorism and how we might
look at those sorts of things using
perspectives coming from ethics which
often I think it's left out of the
picture even though there's a lot of
moral language used with respect to
those things I don't have a big agenda
in mind I thought that I would see where
the audience is on these things and and
do a lot of you know back and forth
responses but I will say this you know
we were talking about this earlier today
you know those of us who have been
around for quite a while and remember
where we were on September 11th and what
happened you know as we're going through
and don't know what what's actually
occurring I remember that that my
response at first when my sister called
me and said hey you got to turn on the
TV was to think well you know they
attacked it once before I remember that
happening while I was in college and
thinking to myself how easy it would be
to do things like that in you know the
various buildings that we had here in
Milwaukee I remember you know talking
with with some of the other security
guards about just how lacks security
really was and you know when it comes
down to it it's quite difficult to
harden targets to the point where they
can't be readily affected and it that is
one of the major changes that we've seen
here in the United States in you know
the last almost two decades since 9/11
we're now getting close to the 20 year
mark and we've seen this vast
proliferation of all sorts of different
security apparatus
and some of them are quite effective and
others are not and I think one of the
things that you could actually talk
about from a moral or ethical
perspective is is there an imperative to
make sure that if you're going to start
implementing new measures and you're
gonna they're definitely things that are
gonna fall upon many people who you know
are not in any way culpable that there's
some sort of payoff so I'm sort of
reliable payoff to it and you're not
just doing as we call it security
theater which I think has been a big
problem here in the United States and
you know in the past not seeing any chat
stuff yet I'm gonna make sure that it's
actually working so let me say hello to
everyone
but yeah so there's a number of
different topics you know I think
another thing that we have to consider
is the cost involved in in these
measures the cost not just in terms of
monetary cost but in terms of all the
other resources that we end up having to
throw into into national security and
preventing terrorism the other thing
that I think that we often leave out too
is it's you know it's terrorism if it's
a readily identifiable enemy but we
often don't call many things terrorism
and that strictly speaking we ought to
be and if we did then we would have to
follow an important guideline in ethics
or critical thinking or reasoning in
general which is to treat similar cases
similarly to say that you know if we're
going to say that the certain things are
off limits for our enemies to do then
then we should also start thinking that
those things are off limits for us and
start thinking about the cost of going
along with them we should you know
acknowledge that our policy has been in
many cases whether we like it or not to
induce terror in populations to produce
compliance from the
so a few questions here from Witcher I
think similar questions from Baca Jose
Josie
Baca jiseon and pear oh by a zot seein a
lot of tough names to pronounce here
do I think torture is completely
indefensible is there ever a situation
when torture is acceptable I mean I I
tend to take a fairly utilitarian line
when it comes to the use of force and
even torture but the question that we
have to ask is is so the utilitarian
line and say that yeah in some cases
it's going to be acceptable but it has
to be for some greater good and it has
to be an identifiable greater good and I
I'm not sure that that's the case in
many of the situations where we do it
the the question about the ticking time
bomb scenario that that's sort of like a
special case of that it's much more
clearer you say well this person has
information about the time bomb that's
going to go off do you torture them do
you use the rest in other ways I mean
you can ask the same thing about lying
to them you can ask the same thing about
other things that we see as moral or
ethical violations are those then
acceptable and the you know one thing to
keep in mind that I think often gets
left out is it's never saying that it
becomes a good thing to do in those
circumstances or the right thing to do
it's just less bad right it's just you
know less unjustified then it would be
in other cases there shouldn't be a
normalization of violence or torture or
these other things that we see as you
know threats to the integrity of the
person and general acknowledged human
rights and I know some of my audience
out there will say human rights you know
they don't exist or they're a figment or
something like that they may well be but
you know you sure as hell want other
people to be recognizing them and we
often appeal to them or rather
inconsistently
malee boy has an interesting comment
here it always boggled my mind as a
foreigner how the USA spends so much
money on warfare when people are
homeless or that money could be used in
other needs how is that humanly moral or
good thinking
and quite honestly the answer is it's
not we do spend far too much of our
resources on the you know not just the
the defense complex but but all the
other things that are associated with it
and we do so in part because it outs you
might say it outsources the casualties
to other people there's this this notion
that well better to fight them over
there then over here and that's been a
prevalent part of our strategy we also
have another part of our strategy that
we've been doing for a long time which
is to substitute you know technological
solutions for for human problems and so
you know we have these incredibly
advanced weaponry systems that can can
you know boost force capabilities but
they're incredibly devastating to the
people who we run across so you look at
you know Iraq and the damage that we did
to it not just in the latest war but in
the first Iraq war where we had very few
casualties but inflicted you know
massive casualties on these these poor
bastards who are stuck out there
conscripted getting bombed you know by
it by us and and you know so we've got
that part of it and we do spend an
extraordinary amount of money and
resources
just on military preparedness not to
mention the extension of US force all
over the place and you can say well if
we didn't do that if we didn't preserve
a sort of stable world order that was
you could say for the time being at
least American american-led right where
we are the hyper power to use the the
term that get coined in the 90s which I
don't think is a status that we're going
to retain you know all
long because we this is not sustainable
but you could say well better us than
the Russians or the Chinese or pick
whoever else and and there may be
something to that or or some you know
just chaos you could say that there's
there's some you know some arguments to
be made there but you could also say
well why shouldn't we be preparing for a
global order where we don't actually run
the show and we have to argue with
people and try to you know cajole them
in to say you know protecting human
rights or preventing genocide or things
like that if it's really just a matter
of if it's all if it's not us it's gonna
be somebody worse than us then I think
we're screwed because we're not gonna
stay on top all that long probably not
my entire lifetime and I have maybe
hopefully another 40 years to go so you
know why are we spending so much I mean
you could you could point to all sorts
of vested interests as a lot of people
do and say well there's a whole industry
that we're supporting and it produces
jobs but that money could be spent on so
many other better things you know I I
think when we look at other countries
and we say well you know national health
care is something that most first world
countries are able to afford it is
something that we could afford if we
wanted to fix things and fix them in a
sort of permanent way rather than just
you know tweaking things here and there
but it's it's just not seen as a major
priority by the the public and the
politicians in the way that it should be
its seen by part of them as a major
priority but even then they don't get it
right I mean we're on Obama care you
know the Affordable Care Act and it's
sometimes very difficult to get to
actually use the insurance that you pay
for in the marketplace that requires
jumping through so many hoops and you
talk to Democratic candidates you're
like what are you gonna do to try to fix
this
they're like the Republicans are gonna
take it away and you're like yeah I
already I already got that what are you
gonna do to make it possible for
ordinary people to use these benefits
that you got them there's no answer it's
weed so we don't really have the
political will unfortunately to do much
all right let me there's a lot of stuff
here people are asking about Dark Star
there's a practice and information
security called hacking back where an
organization attacks its enemies as
retribution or to ward off further
attacks is this ethical in your opinion
it kind of depends on the nature of the
organization to begin with we're talking
about say a criminal organization which
is you know attacking its its opponents
preemptively or just as retribution for
attacking them after say they were
trying to steal information or something
like that I don't think there's much of
a case to be made here that that's
particularly ethical but what about you
know we could talk about again what
about our national security state if
we're constantly getting probed
as we are great obviously by by China I
mean China has been interested in in
cyberattacks for twenty years you know
there's documents out there where they
are like well there's this form of
warfare this form of warfare this form
of warfare and we should do this against
the Americans for a long time
and you know on the Russians and so if
we're pushing back against that you know
is that justified yeah I'd say it is but
we do have to think about what the human
cost is is there spillover to ordinary
people in their lives you know or we
could you know interesting think about
like a huge organization like say Google
or Amazon or or Apple or any of those if
they're Facebook if they're coming under
attack should they you know are they
sort of legitimized to go on the attack
themselves and and you know we might say
well yeah sure but then what if it you
know they start saying well I think that
this is going to be preemptively this is
a strategy for pre-empting potential
malefactors then it starts to get a lot
more dicey doesn't it
[Music]
Friedrich gar gar EP is it progress if
we bargain with ethics maybe Friedrich
Lee asked this question before and
another one I don't know what bargain
with ethics means so you got to rephrase
that in a way that I can answer it
because I have no conception of what
that possibly means Charles Baudelaire I
see what you did there or that you're
streaming simultaneously with Rick Beata
youtube's best music channel it's a sin
I have no idea who who
Rick Beato is if he's not doing classic
metal I probably won't care I mean if
you said that I was streaming at the
same time as you know Iron Maiden or
Raven or or you know LG Ward's tank or
something like that okay maybe then I'd
say okay I should put it on hold for a
bit but I don't have any idea who this
is
alright more stuff more from Baca Juicy
Juice on do I think being able to own a
gun regardless of who you are is a
staple of American national identity
that citizens should be armed that's a
good question so we definitely have what
we what researchers call a gun culture
here right and that definitely does seem
to have a long-standing basis in our
culture early on but you know the notion
of having high high power weaponry you
know where you can even on semi-auto you
can pump out a lot of rounds you can
reload very quickly I would say that's
you know this is one of the things where
we Americans were kind of divided right
and I have a lot of family who are very
very big on guns many of them are I
would say quite you know responsible gun
owners some of them not not quite so
much and I have a you know quite a few
family members who don't have guns and I
don't I don't have a gun myself although
I don't have any objection to own
small numbers if you have more than
three or four guns unless you're you
know a hunting guide or something like
that man I don't want to hear about it
you know it's not really you you could
have other sorts of hobbies other than
investing in hardware like that so I
don't have much sympathy with that at
all is it is it part of the American
identity that's sort of what's at stake
there's a lot of people for whom it
really is part of their identity and you
would say well if it's part of their
identity then you have to let them do
what they want sort of I mean for some
people smoking meth is part of their
identity too we don't say that's a okay
and I'm not light I'm not saying they're
exactly on the same level but you know
you can't just say well it's part of my
identity so therefore I get to do
whatever I want I think that that you
know we this is something that we should
have a real conversation about and I
would love to see the people who muddy
the waters on this namely the people who
are making money either by promoting or
by attacking guns get the hell out of
the conversation
so the rest of us could actually
participate in it that's not going to
happen unfortunately but so you know we
have to decide what we're gonna do
instead and it's very difficult to do
much about it here in the United States
as opposed to other countries but you
know it is something that we ought to do
something about and I don't think that I
mean if if your identity is wrapped up
in owning guns you're badly off you got
problems you know there's so many other
better things to have your identity
wrapped up in all those huxley do I
think deal deontological ethics can
apply an international value judgments
about culture etc can we save objective
ethics from the charge of being
neo-colonial or Eurocentric that's a
good question
so we have to think about what it means
to save something from the charge does
that mean that nobody can we get
ourselves to the point where nobody can
make the charge no because you can
always be attacked by somebody who wants
to say you're doing the wrong thing
you're an aggressor you're a
neo-colonialist you're this or that
right
you'll always have especially in the
internet age you will always have some
detractors right the question is whether
they're legitimate in in saying that and
that's a different question
deontological ethics so when we're
saying des ontological ethics we're
talking about a family of approaches and
and let's strip away some that are going
to be non starters to begin with because
divine command theory can be understood
as a form of deontological ethics but
that's not really going to fly as you're
trying to apply it to to multiple people
in multiple cultures who may not in fact
accept whatever divine command you're
working with what about lysate conscient
ethics or you know WD Rosses and robert
rowdies intuitionist ethics okay there
better prospect right Duty based rule
based ethics is what we're talking about
you could say that the you know the the
focus on respecting rights can be
understood as a de ontological ethics as
well so if you're saying you know we
have to respect human rights is defined
say in the you know United Nations
declaration or if we take particular
countries notions of Human Rights okay
that could be dant illogical as well and
you are gonna find people anytime that
you try to apply that like let's say you
say you can't you know keep women out of
educational opportunities and
institutions and somebody is like well
my culture my culture you know women in
my culture have to be subservient and
that's the way we've always been you can
say well no that's not gonna work
anymore we're not going to go along with
it we're actually gonna put some teeth
in it we're gonna withdraw funding from
you or we're going to you know step in
and do something are you then being
neo-colonial or Eurocentric they're
going to charge you for being so but I
think it can be done in ways that aren't
neo-colonial because you know if things
really if they're really
our universal human values and say you
know human rights and stuff like that
they're not going to be just a matter of
the white European coming in and
imposing them they're gonna be
recognized by by other people and that
seems to be where things are going
paralyzed - Pyatt perro by is it
that's Ian's thoughts on the ethics of
drone strikes
well drone strikes you know that I was
saying that we here in America often
don't make you know we don't we don't
include some of the things that we do as
terrorism that people you know in other
places looking at it say this is pretty
you know terrorist like you're
terrorizing us and I think a lot of
drone strikes the way that they've been
used has been doing that when we accept
collateral damage on a large scale then
that that's a real problem and the idea
of using drones rather than human beings
there's something you know and sort of
putting them up in the sky and you never
know when they're they're coming in it's
clear that that part of the intent is to
coerce a population into doing things
the way that we want them done i I think
that it's I'm not going to say that you
know nobody should ever use drones but
we really need a lot more oversight on
how we're doing it you know and this
applies to both administrations well all
three administrations who are using them
Bush Obama Trump it's not a Democrat
versus Republican issue they've both
been pretty equally bad on this this
sort of thing you know the other thing
that keep in mind - when it whenever it
comes to like Americans and our advanced
military technology we should always
think man how are we gonna like it when
they start doing this to us cuz sooner
or later everything that we do develop
can be turned against us you know if we
think that it's okay to inflict it on
other people then you know we should
think about whether
it's equally okay when it's done sooner
or later to us and we're always like no
no that's terrible the the craven enemy
with their their you know cowardly ways
well how is it any different if we do it
you know and we're the ones who actually
have some measure of control of course
most of us have zero control about what
the national security apparatus does or
what the military decides to do right
but we can at least say we're not for it
here's a really interesting question
from Zanna Scarlett do I personally
believe terrorism is a new face of
conventional warfare that other higher
forces like the USA or others use as
alternative you believe in conspiracy so
oh I see so terror if we're talking
about in terms of terror is there's a
conspiracy right the US would be say
sponsoring terrorism which goes against
the US which then we can respond to and
say we're going to topple this regime or
something like that
I I don't know quite frankly I you know
that that could be the case I'm not
saying it is because I don't have
evidence to say that that's that's the
case and I I think that before we say
something like that really is going on
we probably want to have evidence I
think that I think in a lot of cases the
explanation is closer to the ground you
know I don't think there's some vast
national security conspiracy to produce
terrorism so that then we can use it as
an excuse for national security I think
we have like lots and lots of different
actors many of whom are you know poorly
developed morally and intellectually and
it includes many of our own people
acting in the military and in the
national security state and our
leadership who then you know respond and
and there's a lot of back-and-forth and
you know the thing with terrorism is it
baguettes more terrorism in general and
and is it is it the new face of
conventional warfare yeah you resort to
terrorism when you can't fight the enemy
their own grounds I mean this is what
you know guerrilla warfare is not new
that goes all the way back centuries and
actually millennia we're doing that for
the Romans in Spain you know and when
and in other places as well and also you
don't think about the zealots in you
know ancient Judea
and terrorism has been around for a long
time too
you know the notion I think about what
terrorism is you're using force in such
a way that you attack targets so as to
you know disrupt that society by
inducing terror you know producing the
idea you never know where the blow is
going to fall so people have been
engaging in this for a long time I think
here in America there was a sense before
9/11 that we were rather insulated from
it that most of the rest of the world
didn't enjoy right and so when 9/11
happened I know there's actually pisses
on people off because they're so
emotionally in less than in it from time
to time I was like well you know it
happened here because it happens
everywhere else and you know it's not a
big surprise that sooner or later
something like that would get pulled off
and we're not immune you know not we're
not exceptional in that way except in
the fact that we do push most of it off
on other people so all right are dogie
mo the right wing runs this country ie
supremacy dominates the left has little
power I'd say you know most of the right
has little power to the left and the
right are not monolithic things they're
coalition's of groups and I think in
many respect many of the people who run
the show are perfectly happy to be on
right or left they don't they don't
really care you know they may tie in
with particular things that we identify
with right-wing ideology at the present
or a left-wing ideology at the present
but you know you take a longer
historical view and you know let's take
a gun thing right
the NRA used to actually beef
gun control you know now they're against
it because there was a massive shift and
and it's not just a right-wing shift
right you could call it sort of uh we
probably did a better spectrum than just
right left right for identifying these
sorts of things and I don't think that
the the - you know variable thing of
right left an authoritarian libertarian
works very well either
for categorizing things things are a lot
more complicated than that but I will
say this about you know the elites or
what you're calling supremacy we have a
political class you know we have a lot
of people who made it in and they make
tons of money off of their participation
in politics and their kids don't go to
the same schools as we do and they don't
they don't live the same kind of life
and face the same kind of challenges
that the rest of us do they may have
come from places where originally they
did like Clinton from a trailer park you
know or the way Obama grew up but
they're not they're not part of us well
any any of these people who've managed
to make it up into these these tears
they hurt with the rest of us whether
we're on the left or the right you know
and they for the most part they're
circulating everything within their own
group so all right charles baudelaire
will war as the major cultural narrative
of nations ever get replaced or is it
inherent to the concept of the national
state it's a great question isn't it
what else could take its place that's
the key way of responding to that
actually there's two things what could
take its place is there something that
can mobilize people as much as making
war and then what do you do about the
other countries if you become you know
more enlightened and find some other
great project to engage in what do you
do about the other countries who haven't
gotten the memo and are like no we want
to take you over we don't we want to be
the hegemon that's a little bit harder
to deal with right but are there
countries that have managed to find a
national narrative that works for them
better countries that at one time we're
quite
were like I think so think about the
Scandinavian countries right you may not
you know love the way that their social
welfare state turned out but they
they're pretty invested in that and in
equality they are struggling quite a bit
right now with the issue of what do you
what do you do with with waves of
immigration coming in with people who
don't share those values which is really
one of the major questions for Europe
and for America and for many other
places as well including China by the
way it's that immigration in China it's
more about what do you do with ethnic
nationalities who don't fit in to the
Han Chinese Communist Party dominated a
way of doing things but yeah you can
have all sorts of other prospects but
what do you do about the the fact that
you're gonna have the others the
barbarians at the gates that you have to
deal with good question
even and if you think about it even like
the sci-fi shows that we have like think
about Star Trek right Star Trek is will
stay out this post-scarcity universe the
Federation and get people from from
everywhere you know and all sorts of
backgrounds well they're still
perpetually at war though you know if
it's not the Klingons it's the Romulans
if it's not the Romulans it's you know
this group or that group and much of the
narrative still centers around that or
you know in the show is that centers
around interpersonal relationships you
know his is you know this person gonna
sleep with that person and how are they
going to take it you know or somebody
gets a disease and then they have to
solve that but a lot of it you know it
is difficult to get away from but there
are other things that could substitute
for that all right Bob Lenore lore
Levesque sum up Hegel in three sentences
you know that's impossible
thesis antithesis synthesis yeah anybody
who knows Hegel knows that thesis
antithesis synthesis isn't really Hegel
but you know that's what people put out
there John Fisher choir this is a little
bit different views on decriminalization
of recreational drug use I think
punishing people for using drugs
recreationally is unjust so I I would
say you know personally I am in favor of
decriminalizing drug use of certain
drugs and then not necessarily of
everyone I mean I'm not gonna say yeah
smoke as much meth as you want or shoot
it up as much heroin as you want because
people who do those there isn't any like
just the right amount of math you know
to keep yourself going pot you know a
very different story maybe some of the
other things you know if you think about
ecstasy could be used in in the right
amounts psychedelics maybe aren't going
to be as bad as people have made them
out to be and perhaps if it's done under
controlled circumstances there'd be a
lot less problems coming up and quality
control issues that said right now you
know we've got a real problem when it
comes to this sort of thing because we
have these massive criminal networks
that are how much of this stuff gets to
us so what do we do with that and think
about this those are bad enough and then
what's the alternative is it is it you
know all small business no it's going to
be it's gonna be massive business
growing these things and distributing
them that could be a problem as well but
yeah in general when it comes to when it
comes to recreational use of drugs I
mean I think there have to be some
limits on it don't don't you know say
well hey kids you know 12 years old
here's your kid try them all out or
something like that you know like what I
was in health class
we always have it like every time that
we took health class we had and with the
whole section on different kinds of
drugs and by the way it turns out that
these things these these sections are
terrible for preventing drug use because
kids find out oh well you can smoke pot
and get this sort of effect and you can
like you know do this and get this kind
of effect back when I was a kid of
course it was pot and drinking and
barbiturates that were the the really
big worries that that acid but you know
you you're not gonna say hey anybody
should do whatever the hell
they want but should we should we loosen
the restrictions should we get rid of
these draconian drug laws that put
people in prison for 20 years for very
small amounts of drugs yeah I think so
and I think so we probably should do
that on just on the basis of sort of you
know racial equity you know because the
burden of these things have fallen very
very heavily on minority communities
here in the United States and I imagine
it's probably similar in other places as
well so alright Holodomor you take a
pragmatic standpoint saying the end
justifies the means where it can't
follow on that regard is kind of still
useful today as is formalism and
rationalism of this main outlived itself
Kant thought that that you know ends can
justify means - it's just a question of
which ends right so so there's this
whole thing of saying the ends justify
the means
every ethicist thinks that some ends
justify some means I wouldn't call when
I take a pragmatic standpoint because
I'm not a pragmatist I went to school
with a bunch of pragmatist I would say
that you know you know the stance that I
think is is probably best understood as
sort of a overall virtue ethics
standpoint which incorporates so many
aspects of deontology and utilitarianism
and even ethics of care within it where
did where did can't fall in that I mean
you can if you want to see what content
about politics there's really two main
places to go you've got these essays
like I'm perpetual peace and those are
good to read but there's also the
metaphysical elements of justice you
know there's the groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals the actual
metaphysics of morals is the
metaphysical elements of virtue the
metaphysical elements of justice and
their conscious laying out his view of
social policy and cut you know count is
willing to say have capital punishment
or things along those lines he's not
doing so on you'd like utilitarian
grounds but it's rather you know the
person is like violated their place in
the community they should actually
realize that they need to be executed in
that case
so as formalism of consort outlived
itself I think it's always going to be
useful as a touchstone I mean I think
it's best to understand deontology as
sort of a sort of guide you know guide
rails that we need in place you know I
think it can be useful in that respect
Molly boy do I think World War three
will ever happen I think I hope to god
not if you do think so do you agree it
will wipe out humanity or do you think I
as Eisenhower said nuclear weapons will
cancel out war boy I would hate to see
any more nuclear weapons being used and
and I'd hate to see other things being
used as well we are living in some very
dangerous times not least I mean there
there's danger because of you know
terrorism what if a terrorist
organization gets a small nuclear device
okay that's true right but also because
of you know countries fighting with each
other but we also live in very dangerous
times because you know global climate
change is taking place I mean the RAND
Corporation the military they all know
it's not [ __ ] they all know that
that these pipe dreams that people have
of oh it's not really happening you know
the science is you know there's there's
no real consensus they all know that's
all [ __ ] it is happening I mean how
I can I can look around here in
Wisconsin and see that non-native
species have moved up from Illinois
because it's getting hotter here there's
no snow on the ground like there used to
be when I was a kid staying over the
time and that is really affecting things
across the world it's changing you know
where water is available and how hot the
summers are how much electricity is
needed in order to ensure not just human
comfort but sometimes human life that's
going to destabilize an awful lot of
stuff we also have you know disease
resistance I mean not disease resistant
we have antibiotic
in antiviral resistant bugs coming out
that could turn into a pandemic I mean
we don't need World War three for things
to become completely screwed up you know
we're so dependent upon our logistics
and you know other electronically based
networks what if those go down you know
what if they go down precisely because
we have a pandemic and we can't maintain
them
we're screwed then really really screwed
you know so we could we could be in a
lot of trouble even without World War
three all right
see see war is the result of
appreciating cultural differences I
suppose if the cultural differences are
something like they are gonna kill us
and the only way we can protect
ourselves is killing them you could say
that's the case but I don't know about
that all right TJ bond at the violence
in Yemen seems pertinent if it is
justified in terms of national security
yet manifests as terrorism to civilians
and any sense of ethical justification
or Constitution is missing I don't think
it's justified in terms of national
security you know and I mean there's the
part of the problem is we're not the
only actors there of course the you know
the Saudis and the Iranians have gotten
mixed up in it as well I mean that's the
sort of thing we're probably with the UN
and should be having peacekeepers on the
ground that's one of the problems with
the UN is they're not there often where
they shouldn't be and often not where
they should be but it is terrorism that
you know what goes on there quite often
slow mode is there such a thing as a
just war in your opinion yeah yeah
there's just wars and and you can also
prosecute an unjust war in the part of
it that you're doing justly and you can
also prosecute a just war unjustly you
know and a war can be just in some
respects and unjust and others I don't
think it's like an off
on switch and I think it's important
that before we get involved in Wars we
have these conversations I'd love to see
politicians and decision makers getting
a robust education in some sort of Just
War theory and then when they make the
case having to make a real case about it
but you also have to deal with all the
heel draggers who no matter what you do
are gonna say no you should do more
diplomacy you know give it a give it
more of a chance because because that's
that's a perennial thing as well but
yeah I think there's I think there's
just Wars there probably a lot fewer
than we think all right
lb I'm taking an anthropology course
this fall I wonder what your thoughts
are on cultural relativity in general as
house it might affect ethical issues
such as female genital mutilation well I
mean we so we know that there's cultural
relativity that that's a fact about
about cultures whether they're justified
in maintaining that or whether we should
all be relative this in a prescriptive
sense and say oh gotta gotta respect
everybody's you know cultures and stuff
like that that's a whole different
ballgame the one doesn't necessarily
lead to the other although a lot of
anthropologists push that line pretty
hard don't they you know a lot of the
time that people are relativists you got
to ask what are you getting out are you
being the cool you know enlightened
Westerner who gets to tell all the other
Westerners how to behave you know and
and line themselves up with with the the
other people and make themselves feel
okay are you doing it because you like
to you know stir stir stuff up some
people are relative is you know
sometimes either relativist lines from
people who are about to exploit you and
some people are a relativist because
they want to continue within their own
culture all sorts of exploitative or for
you know dominating practices and i'd
say female genital mutilation is one of
them that that should end you know i
mean if you want to have a continuance
of it let women turn 18 and then decide
if they want
you know have parts removed right as we
do let people do but to inflict that on
children I think that's that's that's
wrong
[Music]
all right TK I know you don't think much
of Sam Harris but I think his attempts
to direct us towards objective ethical
assessments is a good and even valid
cause the reduction of suffering as
conscious beings as ethics require their
be conscious creatures who can suffer
even exist I just had to think with your
previous comment on the invalidity of
the point of some cultures that women
should be regarded as second-class human
beings yeah I mean the thing is Sam
Harris what's good in him has said by
other people so you know I don't I don't
see a hell of a lot there that's worth
spending time on it could be wrong you
know
but that's that's quite often the case
you know that that you can get the same
mileage out of other thinkers who aren't
quite so you know don't have quite a
cult around them of people saying oh
they're so wonderful so great you know
the reduction of the suffering of
conscious beings yeah I mean what's
wrong with that nothing as far as I can
see all right Charles Baudelaire
if a I I'll just scrolled up a bit here
we go
where was that hey I should really reach
human level and we might have Android
soldiers what might it mean for warfare
the ethics of warfare any thoughts well
we'd better hope that the AI was
developed by people who put in ethical
safeguards because I sure don't think
that some AI that is you know highly
developed is going to figure those
things out on its own and man you know
talking to a lot of the people that I
see in the tech sector I'm not super
optimistic about what they're going to
turn out because quite often they they
seem you know they think that that
ethics is way simpler than
it is and they talk that way and and you
know yeah and this is a live issue you
know not just with AI and warfare I mean
think about you know once we actually
have coordinated driverless cars all
over the place including driverless
trucks we better hope that there's been
a lot of thought put into how that's
going to work and probably that won't be
the case probably it's gonna be reacting
to things as they happen
and then trying to fix it on the fly
yeah
NIEM want neem 0:07 do you think social
media websites need to be considered as
public utilities that's a good question
I think that at this point they're
they're becoming so it probably depends
we probably have to look at this case by
case you know right now we're treating
them as if they're all just public
companies you know but we have to ask
what are the goods and we probably need
to think about that in terms of Internet
access as well all right but that's a
big
so I'm gonna put that one off because
actually I've got to get off of here in
less than 15 minutes and I have a lot of
other questions to get to I have to go
over to Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design and teach about Aristotle tonight
all right Wow
J to be to Nick what would Christ say
about the modern political situation I
think he'd be pretty happy I'm a large
part I mean I think he'd I think he'd be
happy about the fact that we do have
participatory democracies in a lot of
places I'm not saying that you know you
can look at the Gospels and see you know
hey democracy is good or something like
that
but if you think about the sort of
involvement of the human person and you
know capacity for agency I think that's
that's that's important but man it's
pretty messed up all over the place
the good news about you know having sort
of the historical view is you realize
it's never been you know particularly
good as far as political situation goes
but then it's it's always been
particularly bad so it's kind of bad
news to Tk I would at one point if said
civilians should never be the deliberate
target of warfare but psychological
warfare especially with regard to
information warfare primarily targets
civilians now it follows up by saying
people watch RT news don't realize it's
an apparatus of the russian informations
warfare plan yeah I mean that is
targeting civilians you know all the
stuff with targeting civilians in terms
of voting is doing that as well is that
it you know should we say that that's
been yeah I think it is you're certainly
and in with social media it's
particularly insidious right because
you're just putting this stuff out there
and you're affecting the the information
landscape in such a way as to make it
difficult to get access to we get good
reliable access to the good information
with
so much disinformation that said you
know so are many of the big you know
lobbying organizations as well they're
they're engaging in misinformation all
the time every time they run a political
ad it's almost always you know
three-quarters misinformation very few
political ads that are not you know
pretty much just just rhetoric but yeah
all right Molly boy do I think the world
would be a better place if we didn't
have countries or religion maybe in the
distant future the world will be like
that or do you think the loss of
tradition patriotism is a bad thing I
guess the question that you have to ask
to answer that is well what's going to
be in place of countries you know the
religion thing was put to the side for
the time being but if we don't have
countries what is going to organize and
structure and rule society corporations
is that going to be better you know than
countries or do we think that somehow
like some anarchist solution is going to
be the case we're going to like form
cooperatives and that's gonna be how
things work you know it really depends
on who else is gonna be in charge that
we don't have country's religion
I don't think religion is ever gonna go
away quite frankly there's always going
to be some people and there's always
gonna be like some people you know
genuinely pursuing the divine in
religion you know reading through the
the wisdom of the past and trying to
come to terms with it and dealing with
the fact that it often makes their
existence much more complicated than
simple and there's always going to be
people using religion for you know just
psychological needs on their part or or
having power over other people or even
man I even know some religious people
who are just know-it-alls and they could
just as easily have been know-it-alls
about some
thing else but they happen to have
picked religion and they're there in the
software Bowl I think those are always
going to be with us
but would it be better if we just
eliminated religion altogether
I mean imagine a future in which you
you're so distanced from religion that
looking at religious texts they became
essentially indecipherable you couldn't
figure out what what these people were
possibly talking about right I mean some
people reading theology from the past
might say that's the current situation I
can't figure out what the hell these
these Trinitarian debates are about or
anything like that but wouldn't you be
missing something in being that kind of
life from what's mattered to other human
beings for a long time or not it's a
good question
all right Jed how do you feel about
William James alternative to war essay
then been a long time since I've read it
and I'm kind of fuzzy about what it was
asserting so I can't can't really say ya
know a.m. laws or maybe it's long law is
if philosophy as a career hadn't worked
out for you what do you think you'd be
doing now for your living good question
I don't maybe I'd be working in an
office somewhere probably I'd be doing
something with education or
communication you know I'm pretty good
at those sorts of things and I'm kind of
drawn to them maybe I'd be working in HR
somewhere you know our management or
something like that my mom wanted me to
be a lawyer and and she even offered to
pay for me to go to law school but I
didn't take her up on X I didn't I
didn't want to do that at the time but I
could I could see being a lawyer
although I don't know if I would have
been happy doing that I'm happier being
a philosopher
Lane with the US government's acceptance
of drone strikes bombing related
collateral damage imply the valuation of
the lives of US citizens over those who
say Iraqis yeah definitely I think when
it comes down to it we not just the
government but also many of the American
people are cool with things to happen to
other people that we would say are
travesty if they happen to Americans
we're not the only people to be in that
that point of view but that is a
prevalent thing you know I remember
during the first Iraq war which I was
against very much in the minority then
right you know first it was listen we
should not be you know getting involved
in this just to secure these oil fields
and there's gonna be a lot of US
casualties and I think that's a terrible
thing and remember I was just shortly
out of the military myself at the time
and then you know when I saw how the war
was being conducted and I and people
were like oh this is so amazing we have
only like a hundred so American
casualties and and I was looking at you
know like the estimated Iraqi casualties
I got I felt sick about that you know
again poor little bastards conscripted
put out there in the desert to get
bombed into into nothingness by by our
superior air force that you know most
most Americans that I talked to they
were like well I guess they had it
coming or that kind of sucks for them
but too bad I mean American lives are
not worth more than other people's lives
from a moral perspective that's it
that's all there is to it you know all
right let's see here proof architect
what do you think a Burton Russell's in
consistent views that some wars in the
21st century were just others were
unjust
well inconsistent in the sense that he's
not he's not saying all wars are unjust
right I mean he if he has criteria that
he's applying across the board he's not
inconsistent
I I think some Wars are just and some
wars are unjust
you know let's see John Wolfe do you
know any x can't speaks about animals
yeah he he talks about the difference
between human beings and the animals in
a variety of places I think you know one
of the places to look is anthropology
from a pragmatic point of view but
that's mostly about people though Daniel
Cox did I think a phenomenology the mind
or spirit is Hegel right points towards
God well it certainly doesn't Hegel's
text right because religion is is the
last section before absolute knowing so
yeah that's that's his view proof
architect here's a good one what are my
thoughts on vigilante justice think
Batman does the status of being a
supposed public moral icon justify
torture or enhanced interrogation so
we're talking about non-state actors
engaging in you know violence or torture
for the sake of the greater good or to
prevent terrible evil from happening
somebody put it out the other day that
was that with Bruce Wayne's resources
you know he he decides to spend him on a
bat cave and bat you know 'mobile and
batarangs and all that sort of stuff and
and he doesn't do some social benefit
stuff right he's a philanthropist but
couldn't even unab it more with I don't
know improving the police force or
something like that so vigilante justice
why does vigilante justice occur it's
usually because of the failure of the
state right and we could ask also about
militias as another example people turn
to that sort of thing when there's
there's a sense that there's not going
to be justice or protection or security
meted out by the state whether it be
because of impotence or corruption or
favoritism or things along those lines
can-can that sort of thing be justified
yeah in some cases it can in most cases
can't because it represents a further
breakdown of order and unless it's
serving some really good purposes you
know once it's really sorely needed it's
probably going to be making things worse
it leads to a factional ization that
breaks down society further all right so
I am going to have to take off I know
there's a lot of other questions and
comments here I'm not getting to but I
got to get to my office hours which
technically are supposed to begin in two
minutes and I've got about you know ten
blocks to walk and I got to get get
dressed and get into the proper mindset
before I go teach these art and design
students about Aristotle and his views
on happiness and friendship so thanks
for all of the questions and comments
we'll do this again on Facebook later on
this month with Facebook live I was
doing one on YouTube and one on Facebook
and I'll see you in the the ether
somewhere at one of these other online
events